SO ONE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS THINK OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S LATEST
COMMENTS?
HERE NOW IS RUDY GIULIANI.
MR. MAYOR, LET'S GET YOUR
RESPONSE TO WHAT MADAME CLINTON
HAS HAD TO SAY TO SAY.
>> IT'S THE MOST INCREDIBLE ACT
OF HYPOCRISY I'VE SEEN.
I MEAN, THE WOMAN BASICALLY
VOTED TO GIVE 20% OF OUR
PLUTONIUM TO RUSSIA.
HER CROOKED FOUNDATION GOT
$150 MILLION.
A HUNDRED $50 MILLION.
HER HUSBAND GOT HER $2.5 MILLION
SPEAKING FEE.
I DON'T KNOW, KIND OF LOOKS LIKE
BRIBERY, SMELLS LIKE BRIBERY,
SOUNDS LIKE BRIBERY.
I'M NOT SAYING IT IS, BUT IT
COMES AWFUL CLOSE.
BECAUSE IF ANYONE WAS GUILTY OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, IT IS
HER.
SHE DID AWAY WITH 33,000 EMAILS,
SHE DESTROYED PHONES, SHE HAD A
GUY DO IT WITH HAMMERS.
THEN SHE BLEACH BIT PER SERVER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DIDN'T DO ANY OF
THAT.
IN FACT, SHE'S NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH.
HE TURNED EVERYTHING OVER TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
DIDN'T OBSTRUCT ANYTHING.
THERE IS NO OBSTRUCTIVE ACT THAT
WAS FOUND EVEN BY MUELLER.
>> Mike: MR. MAYOR, I WAS
SHOCKED THAT SHE WOULD EVEN GO
THERE.
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT SHE
HAD THESE SERVERS, WHAT YOU JUST
RAN THROUGH COMBAT LITANY OF
THINGS THAT EVEN JIM COMEY
WENT ON TELEVISION TO BASICALLY
SAY, YEAH, THIS WAS SO SHE
SHOULD NOT HAVE DONE, BUT HER
INTENT WASN'T THERE, BUT
BASICALLY HE OUTLINED A CRIMINAL
CASE FOR HER AND THEN FOR HER TO
COME AND DO IT, THAT TAKES SOME
REAL AUDACITY, DON'T YOU THINK?
>> MIKE, EVERY ONE OF THOSE ACTS
I JUST MENTIONED AS A TYPICAL
THING YOU PROVE AS EVIDENCE OF
INTENT.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE POWERFUL
AND AN OBSTRUCTION CASE THEN
DESTRUCTION OF EVIDENCE, WHICH
WASN'T PRESENT IN THE TRUMP
SITUATION.
NOR WAS THERE AN UNDERLYING
CRIME.
HE WAS FOUND TO BE EXONERATED OF
COLLUSION, THAT WHOLE RUSSIAN
THING TURNED OUT TO BE A HOAX.
HER CAMPAIGN PLAYED A ROLE IN
PROMULGATING THAT HOAX.
THEY PAID $1.1 MILLION TO THE
PHONY STEELE DOSSIER.
THE ONLY PERSON WHO ACTUALLY
APPARENTLY HAS DONE BUSINESS
WITH THE RUSSIANS IS HILLARY.
AND I THINK SHE'S GOING TO BE IN
FOR QUITE AN EXTENSIVE
INVESTIGATION, AND SHE DOESN'T
HAVE JIM COMEY TO FIX THE CASE
FOR HER THIS TIME.
>> Mike: MR. MAYOR, THE
PRESIDENT WAITED ON US TODAY.
HE HAD A MESSAGE TO THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS.
IT WAS THIS: BRING IT ON.
LET'S WATCH AND WE'LL GET YOUR
REACTION AFTERWARDS.
>> THE SUBPOENA IS RIDICULOUS.
WE HAVE BEEN, I HAVE BEEN THE
MOST TRANSPARENT PRESIDENT AND
ADMINISTRATION OF THE HISTORY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
I THOUGHT AFTER TWO YEARS WE'D
BE FINISHED WITH IT.
NO, NOW THE HOUSE GOES AND START
SUBPOENAING, THEY WANT TO KNOW
EVERY DEAL I HAVE EVER DONE.
WE ARE FIGHTING ALL THE
SUBPOENAS.
LOOK, THESE AREN'T, LIKE, AND
PARTIAL THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TRYING TO WIN 2020.
>> Mike: MR. MAYOR, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> THIS IS A COMPLETELY
POLITICAL HARASSMENT.
ANYBODY CAN SEE THROUGH IT.
JERRY NADLER, ADAM SCHIFF, CUMMI
JERRY NADLER, ADAM SCHIFF, CUMMG
JERRY NADLER, ADAM SCHIFF, CUMM,
THEY WILL PREJUDGE THE CASE A
YEAR AGO.
UNFORTUNATELY, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
AN INABILITY TO CONTROL THEIR
MOUTHS, WE HAVE PLENTY OF
STATEMENTS THAT HE'S GUILTY OF
OBSTRUCTION, GUILTY OF
COLLUSION.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION THAT HE NEVER TURNED
OVER TO MUELLER APPARENTLY OR
LYING, ONE OR THE OTHER.
THIS IS NOT IMPARTIAL ARBITERS
AND THERE IS A VERY GOOD GROUND
TO RESIST THE SUBPOENAS AS A
LEGITIMATE HEARINGS BY THE
CONGRESS.
THIS IS A POLITICAL HEARING.
IT DOESN'T SERVE ANY LEGISLATIVE
PURPOSE.
IT DOESN'T REALLY SERVE AN
INVESTIGATIVE PURPOSE.
MUELLER INVESTIGATED IT.
BY THE WAY, IT IS A SECOND TIME
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THE
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THP
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THI
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THE
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THT
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THO
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THL
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THS
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED THO
AN FBI INVESTIGATION CLEARED TH.
HOW MANY TIMES DOES HE HAVE TO
BE CLEARED OF IT?
SO I WOULD RESIST THOSE
SUBPOENAS AND LET THEM FIGHT FOR
ANYTHING THEY GET AND PROVE
THEIR LEGITIMACY.
>> Mike: ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY WANT TO SUBPOENA IS THE
PHYSICAL BODY OF DONALD McGAHN
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
SOME OF US ARE ASKING OURSELVES,
I THOUGHT THEY WERE TERRIBLE
THINGS THAT WERE SACRED.
ONE WAS A HUSBAND AND WIFE
TESTIFYING NEXT TO EACH OTHER
AND THE OTHER WAS THAT YOU
CANNOT COMPEL A LAWYER TO
TESTIFY AGAINST HIS OR HER
CLIENT.
SO WHAT AM I MISSING?
HELP ME OUT.
I'M NOT A LAWYER, I AM PROUD TO
SAY, YOU ARE.
SO YOU HELP ME TO UNDERSTAND
THIS UNDERSTAND THIS.
>> [LAUGHS]
I FIND IT TO BE EXTRAORDINARY.
THEIR REQUESTS DEFY EVERY
CONSTITUTIONAL NORM I CAN THINK
OF.
THE REALITY IS THAT MICHAEL
COHEN TRASH THE ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE WHEN HE TAPE HIS
CLIENT AND LIED TO HIM ABOUT
IT AND THEN ACTUALLY DOCTORED
THE TAPE.
THERE IS NO REASON TO
INTERROGATE DONALD McGAHN ANY
LONGER.
HE WAS QUESTIONS FOR 29 HOURS.
HE MUST HAVE GIVEN HIS ENTIRE
HISTORY GOING BACK TO BIRTH FOR
29 HOURS.
MUELLER COULDN'T GET OUT OF HIM
WHAT HE WANTED, IT JUST
ISN'T THERE.
SO THIS BECOMES NO HARASSMENT.
IT BECOMES REALLY A VIOLATION OF
SEPARATION OF POWERS.
CONGRESS IS GOING SO FAR HERE,
THEY ARE INTERFERING WITH THE
ABILITY OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
TO FUNCTION.
81 SUBPOENAS BEFORE THE REPORT
WAS EVEN FILED.
I MEAN, THEY DECIDED THIS BEFORE
THEY READ THE REPORT.
JERRY NADLER WAS OVERHEARD ON
THE TRAIN COMING DOWN FROM
NEW YORK TO WASHINGTON TAUNTING
AND IMPEACHMENT.
A WEEK AGO, ONE OF HIS AIDES
WITH HERDS DOING THE SAME THING.
SO THEY CAN GO TRY TO FOOL
SOMEBODY ELSE, BUT NOT
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Mike: I GUESS I'M HAVING A
HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING,
IMPEACHMENT IS NOT GOING
ANYWHERE, NOT WITH US SENATE IN
REPUBLICAN HANDS, AND IS GOING
TO BE A BIGGER FAILURE THAN
IT WAS WITH BILL CLINTON IN
1998.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
PUSH IT?
IT ACTUALLY HELPED BILL CLINTON.
DO THEY NOT THINK THE SAME THING
WILL HAPPEN TO DONALD TRUMP?
>> LET ME MAKE A DISTINCTION.
BILL CLINTON WAS GUILTY OF A
CRIME.
IT'S CALLED PERJURY.
WHEN THE DRESS WAS PRODUCED, HE
HAD TO STOP LYING ABOUT IT,
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD STILL BE
LYING ABOUT IT NOW.
HE AND HILLARY WOULD BE TRASHING
MONICA LEWINSKY.
HE GOT CAUGHT AND HE HAD TO
ADMIT HE COMMITTED PERJURY,
LYING UNDER OATH.
MAYBE IT WASN'T SEERY ENOUGH   E
MAYBE IT WASN'T SEERY ENOUGH   I
MAYBE IT WASN'T SEERY ENOUGH   S
ENOUGH, MAYBE IT WAS PERSONAL,
BUT IT SURE WAS A CRIME.
IN THIS CASE, THE PRESIDENT WAS
FOUND TO HAVE NOT COMMITTED AN
UNDERLYING CRIME.
THE REALITY IS, THE PRESIDENT'S
CONDUCT IS HE EASILY.
THIS IS A MAN WHO WAS FALSELY
ACCUSED AND EVERYTHING THEY LIKE
TO SAY IS OBSTRUCTION AS A MAN
TRYING TO DEFEND HIMSELF AGAINST
VERY UNFAIR, EXAGGERATED,